sick hair it's like i threw you up there
myself
what's up football nerds what's up oh
wait is rogers already being the
competitive bully
oh come on we're all mvps here you want
mine
i'm about to get a number russ here is
his generation's drew brees great player
but someone's always better hey russ i
made us jackets
let's race winner gets control of the
mountain loser never comes back
what no let's just wait till next year
man next year where on your mark
get set hold on come on aaron remember
why you're racing
[ __ ] the packers i'll prove them around
by winning them a lot of games nice try
but i upgraded my weapon did you guys
think analytics enriches sport are cheap
in russ has to lead but rogers and brady
are keeping up hey lamar come join the
rest of the okayqb's derek's doing a
poetry reading coach screams screams
screams
but i dream dream dream i wanna go far
but i'm just another used car ah
no my board but my defense reinforced it
we have to support rust with the strong
oh wait the jets are on look at gays
yo i think something seriously wrong
with your situation
with old spice triple protection sweat
defense i'm unstoppable hey can i try
that
uh sure the live game holding face mask
intentional grounding oh i haven't even
broken a sweat everyone i'm so sorry
about this he's got triple protection
it looks like it's now a race between
rogers and my homes you know i also won
mvp once
that's not healthy watch out for me
household name dalvin cook
do you smell what the dalvin is oh wait
this is straight up just a clip
man did he not see last year's episode
yes anybody else having trouble with the
wi-fi
i could actually win take that dad i
mean belichick i mean aryans yo what up
man want to see me make something out of
nothing
that child is going to die i knew you
down there somewhere no more new people
hey guys have you seen all the snow it's
like buffalo in the summer
josh allen hanging in with the big one
wait where's my homes did y'all do a
split screen without me
the girl deserves mvp for putting on a
season
[Music]
and let's thank baker for the
snickerdoodles yeah gluten
free baby so thoughtful later on kirk
will sing us a song
i'm gonna scream a creed song at you all
that sounds
delightful but first a poem for me
i'm a lion to myself